so my name is Francisca and I talk about
JavaScript performance javascript
compiler specifically v8 because I used
to be on the v8 team and that's the
compiler and nodejs an electron and
chrome of course so we'll look at
performance of modern JavaScript how it
compares to performance of C++ and then
very briefly we're web assembly fits
into this performance discussion now why
would you care about the compiler
ideally it's just there compiling your
code and you don't have to worry about
it and also you really should never
write code specifically for compilers to
get certain performance obviously this
doesn't work on a browser at all because
you can't control what browsers your
clients are running but even for
server-side applications for node and
electron do not cater specifically to
the compiler because what the compiler
is doing internally performance wise
it's not part of the JavaScript
specification it's not in a contract in
the API it can change at any time I mean
v8 is updated every six weeks and even
between those six weeks they're they're
patches and fixes so if you have
anything that you wrote because you
thought it's faster if you do it this
way
it can change anytime and it's just not
what you should be doing so why would
you care about learning some of the
internals and the abstract concepts of
modern JavaScript engines well having an
idea of what's going on under the hood
will make you a better developer you can
think about it kind of like driving a
car anybody can learn how to drive a car
without needing to know anything about
the engine if your car's broken or for
inspection you take it somewhere and
they fix it and you just drive your car
and it's all good
but if you want to be a professional
racecar driver or a really good driver
and bad weather conditions it will be
helpful if you have some idea of what's
going on under the hood in the engine so
it's a little bit similar with
JavaScript having some idea about it
doesn't mean you have to like dig into
it and make a big mess and then like be
slower the next time we push another v8
release it just means you have better
understanding and will help you
eventually when you have performance
issues or when you try to figure out
what's going on okay so the talk is
titled speed speed
feet and we're talking about performance
I want to point out I'm talking only
about the runtime performance so the
runtime performance of JavaScript C++
and web assembly I'm not talking about
all the other things that usually make
your app slow so I'm not talking about
IO a data basis or HTTP or rendering or
different frameworks like those are
usually the big things you can target
when you need to improve performance
there's also usually the things that
really slow stuff down we're just
looking at how long does it take to run
javascript code not sending anything
over the wire not having other
bottlenecks just the JavaScript code
itself and then a big warning never ever
blindly optimize you just create a ton
of bugs and make it hard to maintain
your code this should be obvious but I
want to say it anyways don't blindly
optimize always measure first make sure
you even have a performance issue like
yeah make sure you have a performance
issue that you want to address and then
measure and figure out where your
bottleneck is don't just say oh I heard
this talk I learned some stuff about
compilers I'm going to make every
function monomorphic no no no because
that's gonna give you such a tiny
speed-up if at all probably not even
because compilers are complicated like
don't go and optimize unless you've
measured and you'd figured out what you
need to optimize all right before we can
talk about performance I want to point
out one fundamental difference between
dynamically scripted language a
dynamically typed scripting language
like JavaScript and a statically typed
scripting language statically typed
language like C++ not a scripting
language okay so in JavaScript if you
want to have a property X on an object
you can do this at any time you say
define a variable object assign it sign
an object to it and then set this
property X to 40 to perfectly valid code
can you do the same thing in C++ you
pretty much can accept C++ compilers are
a little stricter and you first have to
tell the C++ compiler what the tybor the
shape of object is so you first have to
define a class where you tell the
compiler
this class has a field that's public and
it's an integer and it's called X okay
and then once you have this class
declaration just like in JavaScript you
can say object object and set to
property X 242 not nothing really
special but now in JavaScript if you've
changed your mind if other data is
coming in you can always say oh I also
need this Y field on my object it has
value 17 if the same change of mine
happens to you in C++ compiler is gonna
be like no no no I'm not this is not
working like this right so anybody who's
written any C++ before you always have
to figure out what the object type is
define your class and then you can use
it you cannot just randomly add
properties or delete them like you can
do in JavaScript and because you can
change the types all the time like this
in JavaScript it's called a dynamically
typed language it's not static like C++
you can change things dynamically as you
need them say you're getting JSON over
the wire and you want to put this JSON
into an object you don't have to first
up say oh it's going to have these
properties and now assigned adjacent to
it no you just take the JSON and it's
dynamically creating these object types
um that can be really nice when you do
work with things like Jason it's also
very nice when you're just learning a
language when you're prototyping
something but for a compiler it's a lot
of work because you're not telling the
compiler upfront what will happen so in
fact if you do something simple like a
property look up in JavaScript and
obviously you do object dot X all the
time like just to cancel that lock
you're looking up the log property on
console like it's all over your code you
can't live without it but there's a lot
of things that can happen when you have
this tiny little dot for a property look
up in your code what happens if you do
this you could get a type error X could
be undefined X could be undefined on
object but be defined further up on a
prototype chain X could be be a proxy
but the get trap X could have been
defined with an axis or descriptors you
have
and I get function which can do whatever
side effects you wanted to do and even
if X is defined on the object and the
compiler still doesn't know where to
find the value of x and the memory
layout of object because the compiler
doesn't have a blueprint of this object
if it's c++ the compiler knows okay
object belongs to the class object and
this is the memory layout and it's never
going to change
javascript compiler sadly doesn't know a
lot so there's a lot of things that can
happen for something as simple as this
and in fact in the ECMO scripts
specification so don't worry about
reading all this I macroscope specifies
how JavaScript has to be implemented
what should happen and so just a simple
property look up if eight steps here
sorry
making sure everybody's awake so in the
specification something very simple like
a property lookup is a ton of steps and
in fact each one of those steps here is
another long list of ten steps or so so
everything's really complicated in
JavaScript it's not just oh you get this
property and you're done no no there's
like lots of things well if it's
undefined if it's on a prototype chain
if it's a proxy if it's a get Travis one
so if everything if just if like the
tiniest little bit of work as a ton of
work for JavaScript compiler what's our
intuition about JavaScript performance
it's this JavaScript performance well
instead of intuition let's look at some
data so I was calculating some prime
numbers and I did it in C++ and
JavaScript exactly the same I won't go
rhythm and I think this slide is super
amazing like yes javascript is slower
than C++ here but this is a linear scale
and JavaScript is less than effect a to
slower like that's kind of the same
speed right like yes it's a little bit
slower but it's not exponentially slower
or anything you can calculate the
millions prime number and it would take
you eight seconds with my terrible C++
algorithm but the same terrible
JavaScript algorithm only takes 15
seconds it's not that much worse okay
you're shaking your head it's twice as
slow but it's it's actually really good
if you go back to this other slide where
you think about how much work it is for
a compiler that should just get a
property of an object this is absolutely
amazing
so how can modern JavaScript be this
fast the trick that all modern engines
use is just in time compilation
just-in-time compilation sometimes
called lazy compilation often
abbreviated as JIT compilation you can
turn it into a warp and say it's this
code jittered so it's a just-in-time
compiled and that means JavaScript
compilers only compile the code as you
random just-in-time
they're not compiling everything ahead
of time generating and executable that
you don't run it's compiling just in
time as you need to run some code so
your typical compiler 2 will change you
always start with some source code
obviously and then the compiler or the
engine has a positive this human
readable source code and turns it into
an abstract syntax tree and ast so
that's the different representation of
your source code that's more suitable
for
Judis to reach than the actual source
code and then the interpreter or
compiler depends on what language you
talk about in the context the
interpreter or compiler then takes this
abstract syntax tree and generates
machine code and you can run this
machine code on so that's your typical
compiler tool chain now for just-in-time
compilers it's not a one-way tool chain
anymore instead it's a loop here where
the compiler generates some machine code
a little bit of machine code is run and
then we go back and compile more code
into machine code so there's this
constant alternation between
compile-time and run-time so we're
compiling a little bit we're running it
and then we go back to compiling some
more and running more how is this faster
how is this a plus this just sounds
really messy and like you would have a
ton of overhead for going back and forth
all the time well the big trick here is
by running some of the code the compiler
can gather information from runtime some
runtime feedback so this is information
that the compiler doesn't see by looking
at the source code or the abstract
syntax tree this is information it only
gets from running the code and then this
runtime feedbag is used in the next
compilation step that's the big trick
why switching back and forth between
compiling and runtime can actually speed
up JavaScript even though it sounds way
more complicated and saying compile
everything run everything by switching
it up the compiler can get information
from runtime and use that to generate
faster machine code the next time it's
compiling so JavaScript compilers they
use feedback collected at runtime to
speed up the performance okay and that's
actually not enough to get this amazing
performance where we're almost as fast
as C++ since 2011 chrome was the first
one and then a few years later the other
major engines also added add they all
have at least two compilers they have a
baseline compiler and then they have at
least one optimising compiler so Safari
doesn't have one optimising pilot has
two optimizing compilers even and this
optimizing compiler it recompiles hot
functions
so a function that is being run a lot
that could pass to the optimizing
compiler and when a compiles machine
code for heart function it uses runtime
information it speculates that the
future of inputs will be similar to what
it saw in the past it's making a
speculation about what data it will get
and it's optimizing the machine code for
that and if it turns out that the
speculation was wrong that the future is
not the same as what it saw in the past
then it will just de optimize and fall
back to the baseline compiler alright so
that was very abstract let's look at
this more concretely with code so if
this really complicated function he has
an example of function add takes an
object returns one plus the X property
of this object everybody clear on that
function right okay so in our touching
here we have two source code and then
the positons
this add function into an abstract
syntax tree when we run the function and
now the baseline compiler generates
machine code for this add function and
in my example I'm calling add a few
times and I'm always calling it with a
regular object that only has a field X
that has an integer value like it's an
object there's nothing special about the
prototype chain it doesn't have any
other fields than then X and the value
of x is always different numbers it's
not the same number like it's not always
that the answer is 42 even though that's
the answer to everything it's not the
same number but it's always small
integers and it's always the same shape
of an object that we're passing in to
add okay so I'm running this function
many times so at some point this
function is considered hot because we
get this feedback from the runtime hey
this add function is being executed a
lot so the function is hot and the
optimising compiler takes over and it
recompiles the source code for add but
now it can use the information the
speculation that we will call this
function always with an object that's a
regular object with nothing special on
the prototype chain that has an X
property and nothing
so we're speculating that the future
input will look similar to the inputs in
the past and so this machine code that
comes out runs much faster than the one
on the left but it only runs if this
speculation is right now of course in
JavaScript it's totally legit to call a
function a thousand times with similar
inputs and then at some point change
your mind and say oops
changed my mind calling this add
function with a different object now um
this does not give you wrong JavaScript
it's not that your code will crash or
anything it's just for the compiler this
optimized machine code will give you the
wrong result if you were to run it with
this kind of input so instead of running
the optimized input the optimized
machine code the compiler D compiles and
passes on this input to the machine code
that was generated by the baseline
compiler so it's the slower version but
it's correct for this kind of input okay
and so here's actually the x86 assembly
code that's being generated by the aid
for this little odd function that I
showed you and the left-hand side is
what's generated by the baseline
compiler it runs on for a few more pages
I couldn't fit everything on here but
these four lines on the right hand side
is what's generated by the optimizing
compiler and this is both for the same
ad function it's does add function takes
an object returns one plus object at X
and obviously every instruction takes
some time so if you have lines and lines
of instructions it's way way slower than
just four lines of instructions and this
might look very cryptic but it's
actually not that hard especially
because we know what this little add
function is doing so if we look at these
four lines of code they're the first
line is cmp compare this is where we are
comparing that the input matches what we
were speculating so we have this hidden
class in the background in v8 where we
sort of write down what an object shape
looks like and we're just comparing that
the new input matches what we've seen in
the past because only for that kind of
input is the optimized code
right so this is a little check or guard
before we can use the optimized code and
then the next slide line is
JM jump that's we're jumping bail out so
we are bailing out to the D opt to the
baseline compiler if the comparison
didn't hold so if you're trying to run
the optimized code and the input didn't
match the speculation that the compiler
made in the beginning if the if the
input is not of that shape with just an
X with an integer then this optimized
code is jumping it's bailing out to
these long list of instructions on the
left if our speculation does hold though
then we only have two more lines to run
morph is a move instruction this is
where we're moving the value of X to
another register and this is a simple
move instruction because we speculated
on the shape of the input so the
compiler actually knows the memory
layout off it so it's easy to access the
x value and then the last one at that's
just addition where we're adding one to
that value of x so this is how those
four lines translate to the add function
but if you can't make that speculation
in the beginning that you have a certain
kind of input then you're stuck doing
several hundred instructions on the left
and as I said doing hundreds of
instructions are slower than four
instructions so you can actually run the
eights of node and Chrome an electron
with a flag where you say - there's no
optimization and that's your upper
picture
so before javascript engines had a
second optimizing compiler you were
stuck with the upper picture where now
C++ is way faster than JavaScript and
you can't say oh this is amazing we're
almost at native speed no no if you
don't have the optimizing compiler now
it takes you eighty seconds instead of
ten seconds but if you just use the
optimizing compiler like the default
then you're pretty much in the same
ballpark with JavaScript as with native
C++
and then this one this slide is amazing
to me because you can see the optimizing
compiler in the data so here i zoomed
into the first 200 iterations and at
first
javascript is a lot slower than c++
right if you look from 0 to 50 years so
it's a lot slower and then it actually
spikes a ton like it's not even on the
graph anymore that is where the
optimizing compiler is recompiling your
source code because obviously
recompiling something also takes time so
you don't get it for free and that's
what's why we can't optimize everything
all the time because it's a trade-off
between is it worth optimizing this
function but we're counting the same
function here over and over again and
the prime number calculation so it's
considered hot and it is being optimized
and then around the hundreds prime
number that's when you see in the data
that the optimising compiler has
finished compiling and we're now running
the optimized machine code so you can
literally see where's the warmup period
for the optimizing compiler when it's
done compiling and you see that when you
measure how long it takes to run it if
you want to play around with any of that
if you use node you can just do - - and
then the v8 options for example trace
optimization or trace the optimization
that will list which function is being
optimized and when is it being T
optimized if you use Chrome you just do
- - Jas Flags equals and then use these
flags you can also print the assembly
code if you want to see them and there's
like a really long list of more options
either check the source code or like
ping me on Twitter and they give it to
you there's a bunch of websites of repos
that actually just list them ok all
right
so I was comparing JavaScript to C++ and
we saw that modern JavaScript is
actually pretty good compared to native
C++ if you do need more speed than
JavaScript if you really do have
something that's computationally
intensive and you cannot deal with it
that it's twice as slow that javascript
is still twice as slow as C++ if you
write node or an electron app then you
can write native add-ons so that is code
written and C++ but you use it like a
JavaScript module so users of your
library don't have to worry that this is
C++ code that you give them they will
just do require module and then they
just call whatever function they want
from your API some popular examples that
you might be using already as notes ass
or GRP see a lot of things that work
with encrypt cryptography like bcrypt
and also sequel light 3 they all use
native add-ons but when you use it you
don't need to know any c++ or you're not
using the modules any different than you
would use a JavaScript module and
obviously you can use native modules and
electron works very similar to when you
just use them and note and if you want
to play with any native modules we have
it on the official note jester dork
documentation the hello world and a few
other things and it's it's really not
that hard to write a native module
there's two things that you need you
need a build file for jib a binding the
jib file that gives some instructions
which C++ file to use and then in your
C++ code that you have anyways for the
functionality that you want to implement
you just need a little bit of
boilerplate C++ because in C++ you kind
of need to wire together the French name
in JavaScript to the method name and C++
I think it's not all magic but it's
really just boilerplate code so this is
the sample build file
the important part here is that we're
saying used to fire prime stat CC and
put the output into primes you need to
give names to things and you also need
to tell the build 5water your C++
sources and then in the C++ code so this
is my prime set c c we have the prime
number algorithm at the top there's just
a little bit of boilerplate here so in
this function here we are wiring the
JavaScript string prime to method so
that when a user that's using your
module is saying module that Prime
they're getting the right method and
then the method itself we just have to
say oh the method is wired to our C++
function Prime in the namespace prime so
this looks a little complicated my
opinion it's the typical copy and paste
kind of situation and then you make sure
you why are your function names
correctly so yeah you can write native
C++ code and use it a node or electron
and anybody who's using your module
doesn't need to know anything about C++
just pretty nice okay so we compared
JavaScript and C++ and obviously can
write JavaScript anywhere back and in
browser anywhere where you have a
JavaScript engine you can write native
C++ add-ons when you have node or
electron not on the browser where does
web assembly fit into this and where
does it fit in a performance story I
would say very very little about web
assembly because we have two more talks
today from people who know way more
about web assembly so stay for those
talks briefly web assembly is a portable
binary format for the web portable that
means you can put it from machine to
machine if you write it at runs on
Windows Mac and Linux you don't have to
worry about the architecture it's a
binary format that means it's binary so
it's not for us humans it's for the
computer to read and it's for the web
that means it runs in the browser so
it's a binary format something did we
cannot read right away that runs in the
browser and it's supported on all
platforms
multiple browsers that's actually
something really really nice all the big
browser when this came together and
worked together on the specification and
they're still working together under
specification and they all agreed yes we
will implement webassembly according to
the specification so you can actually
use it because there's no point of
having something great and the browser
if it's only supported by one browser
because then you can't usually you can't
use it for any real life work so it's
it's really nice that these major
companies came together and said we work
on this together we're not doing a
competition and just one person
implements it I think know you can wear
assembly is supported in all the major
browsers since web assembly is supported
by the 88 it's a node you can run
webassembly and node and I said it's a
binary format so it's not a language
that it's not like you learn the web
assembly syntax and then write web
assembly now you write in your language
of choice and then you can compile
almost any language to web assemblies so
there's more and more compilers coming
up the obvious ones are C++ and rest but
there's also go and Java and lower
compilers and many more all right so
what about performance so javascript is
still the slowest c++ is the fastest and
web assembly is in the middle there just
a little bit slower than c++ and that's
kind of what you would expect if you
know a little bit about web assembly
it's not just in time compiler it's
statically typed and there's just this
tiny little overhead because you have to
switch from c plus you're calling web
assembly that's why it's not as fast as
c++ but it's very close
so in summary modern javascript is
really really fast it's not like 20
years ago but it's also not like 2011
that was the slide where I showed you 10
seconds versus 80 seconds we are at less
than a factor 2 for things that are
computationally expensive so unless like
there's a very small amount of
applications that really need
this kind of performance for the
computational part so most of the time
you're probably just fine sticking with
JavaScript you don't have to worry about
a different syntax you don't have to
worry about build tools your CI like
just keep everything in JavaScript it's
almost as fast as C++ and it's probably
good enough for what you're doing if you
earn these rare cases but you really
need that performance and yes all apps
pretty much all apps should be faster
especially if you don't slow Wi-Fi but
that's not solved by like changing from
JavaScript to C++ like it's probably
because you're doing the wrong HTTP
calls or you're sending pictures that
are too big or your database is too slow
but if you do fall into this small
amount of applications where your
runtime performance is really really
important then you can always as long as
it's no two-electron and not in the
browser you can opt for native add-ons
and just write it in C++ and if you do
need something really fast in the
browser
try out web assembly but before you do
any of that make sure you measure first
and don't optimize blindly thank you
[Applause]